the Joe Rogan experience that video of
you that they play where you were a
really young kid where you were just
getting into fighting I was I was 15
years old I was I was he living grade we
shot that when I was 11 grade and that's
when myspace was poppin Wow
did you have a myspace I had a myspace
and I was that was like mrs. hoppy my my
old trainer at the time the guy who my
boy my boy who got me into fighting
Joshi on one of my friends birdie-bird
this guy named Chechen la polo my older
brother my younger brother one of my
cousins and then another cousin I
remember a whole toffee and then you got
to change like to top 16 and 24 and
people was being like getting mad when
you taught me that who is 102 right
right you know III make the sixteen one
I'm like you should be happy you on
there right people get mad yeah it was
game at was crazy but uh but he wanted
to be a number one yeah but then what's
funny what's funny about that video
because at the ending that video they
showed in the in the countdown they
showed me saying like if you loser it's
like if you try least you and win in
your book you know whatever loser coat
yeah that coat was like on people's
Bibles you know like the bile you know
you're gonna put a quote or whatever
status and LT was bad I was like yeah
your boy made it because they made
thousand ashes a one nationally it was
for stn Awards that when the schools
come up and they did do stuff and
whatever you say it's here in California
whenever do and I was supposed to go
that's my 11th grade year and I was kind
of mad that I wasn't able to work get it
but it was just it was just cool it's
cool it's gotta be weird looking at
yourself when you're 15 talking about
you know oh yes my accent was like eyes
that have accent but I still talk a lot
but like now that I said what would you
say to Talk Talk Moke Moke yeah omocha
is like or pigeon okay is
like that's why actually I can talk to
languages I can talk a pidgin is
actually a whole language now is it
ruined yeah they made a language really
yeah Google it how much different is it
like if you were gonna say something to
Jamie like if you're gonna say Jamie hey
Jamie my car is coming soon
I gotta get the [ __ ] out of here I'm
like oh something [ __ ] where's my car
oh that's normal yes up you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's a Hawaii is a strange place because
I feel like it should be its own country
I really do but I like the fact that
it's protected by the United States you
know you know they wanted you know Dana
Dana Dana had had to approve me walking
out with my flag really
there was never there wasn't gonna let
me walk with the horn flag why any even
like the even with Vegas uh when I first
started doing it when I cuz that's when
the Reebok came out we couldn't do no
whole I couldn't pull Hawaiian flag on
my shorts or anything so I was like I'm
gonna walk out the flag and then Reebok
was stopping it does I can can't because
it's a state flag yeah whatever yeah and
then I was like what I was like nah no
no we could talk to Dana and then so you
could come out with a clique of you're
from Nigeria you can come over the
country [ __ ] country and then and then
they know right then talk to Dana them
and they told me cuz like they know Dana
texted me and he said yeah it's to be a
[ __ ] kid just walk with it it's like
come on
like let this kid represent Hawaii like
like how you said because he says it's
like there are people you know people
just let him just let him represent and
then they did it it's five hours in a
plane across the ocean that [ __ ] is
barely America Hawaii is amazing I love
it it's one of my favorite places to
visit I go there three four times a year
I love Hawaii but that is not America I
love that they're protected by America I
love that I love all the rights yeah you
know I love all that but I feel very
strongly that they should have their own
it should be sovereign it's it's you
know they should have their own it's
it's their own thing man how the [ __ ]
you gonna claim something that it takes
five hours to get to on a plane yeah
it's not even attached [ __ ] it
it's crazy it's crazy and I but again I
love that it's protected by America I
loved it
we're considered to be from the same
country I love all that but every time I
go to Hawaii I'm like come on man this
place is different there Hawaiians like
if you go to North Dakota you can't look
at someone to go oh that's a North
Dakotan right you go to Hawaii like all
that dude so why is a Hawaiian guy you
know Polynesian I mean there's there's
so many people in Hawaii that they're
clearly Hawaiian yeah I mean it's
there's no state like that
there's no Alaska you don't look at
someone I mean they get a full beard
flannel coat and [ __ ] moose leg over
their shoulder maybe that's an Alaska
you're guessing yeah he might have moved
there yeah you might just be a mountain
man yeah 100%
it's a great place though this is a the
thing about Hawaiians that they have
like when you're on an island and you're
surrounded by ocean there's like a
reverence for nature yeah that Hawaiians
have yeah that I really like yeah you
never did you never see my hiker
Holloway's what is that hiker Holloway
hiker Holloway yeah I got you tube we
got it we got a guy named hike Holloway
who's hiker Holloway you're looking at
the man you you have a youtube video we
just hiked hiker Holloway what the [ __ ]
is this oh this is a [ __ ] you did
recently yeah you did this in Vegas
right Canyon isn't that funny that Red
Rock like just outside of Vegas it's
like a whole nother world like you might
as well be on Mars yeah yeah it is it
looks like Mars Izzie you survival tips
goes to YouTube guys and you know I
break down plants there's a plant that
you see in there what plant you cannot
it's caught it's got a ladder tree but
yeah you need to go and see stuff do you
actually know what you're talking about
you're talking to
hiker Holloway surviving in the
wilderness all max s max
Oh max is going to like I like it all
Maxis
[Applause]